all right Abraham yes sir where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
um I'm from Jersey City New Jersey I was
born and raised
um born in Christ Hospital located in
Jersey City and lived in the same house
for the entirety of my first 22 years of
my life
tell me about your family
um I had an excellent family a
stay-at-home mom dad owned the business
and works for the state
um and they did everything in their
power to you know provide me
a more than great childhood you know
anytime I ever needed anything they were
always there for me
um
and yeah I guess I kind of started to
take that for granted and as it went on
but
how'd you end up down here
um all right so um yeah so
my parents find out that um I'm using a
substance and my mom Googles it finds
out that it's heroin and um what was
that what age were you
um I was 22 23. and
um yeah so they sent me down and they're
like hey you know um you you got to do
something like you're not gonna be in
our house doing heroin you know it's
unacceptable
um my parents are very old-fashioned no
smoking weed no drinking you know
there is are you Jewish um no I'm
Colombian and Egyptian I'm Christian
okay as far as religion
um
so yeah
um it was close to Christmas I agreed to
go like after Christmas and New Year's
and I went to a spot in Fort Lauderdale
um the first facility was in 80 bed
facility in Fort Lauderdale
um and I went to that spot I want to say
six times back to back
um just never really getting it you know
what I mean I think I was doing it for
the wrong reasons I was just waiting for
the 30 days to be over just so that I
can you know go back to doing what I was
doing
[Music]
um
to push forward a little bit
um
since those facilities had so many
people
um I got in contact with a lot of people
that shared the same problem that I did
and um eventually I got tired of going
to Florida
um because it wasn't working and I
thought it was maybe the location
uh so somebody told me about California
and I went over to California
um and not even within my first
treatment center and did I find out
about a um
get down I guess you could call it
um that uh involves paying an individual
for attending uh treatment
and that very quickly
ah how do I word this properly that very
quickly spiraled out of control just
because of the uh
the amount of funds that were being
exchanged in order you know there's a
term for this right yeah it's called our
body program right yeah
um there's a movie out about it actually
uh called body Brokers it's a really
great movie and um surprisingly it's
pretty accurate as to like everything
you know they they the rehab scene is
not as simple as just sending an addict
to rehab and getting clean no more
that's not it's not it's not it's really
not a thing anymore whether it's a
legitimate Treatment Center that doesn't
pay the client and um you know just does
it the way they're supposed to there's
still somebody receiving uh you know
like a commission check for that person
going through
um but where it gets really down and
dirty is when um that person that
receives it the person on the intake
call ends up sharing it with the client
um because you have a drug addict that
just finished 30 days of treatment you
know six thousand dollars what do you
expect them to do and they're going to
go right back to using you know what I
mean and they very well might die
because they lost most of their
tolerance
um they have an unlimited amount of
funds to you know get high and they're
in a foreign place where you know they
don't really know the the substances
um fast forward a little bit more
um I did really really well with this uh
I guess you could call it a job
um I linked up with a uh
an owner
um and we got along really well because
uh he was Middle Eastern as well uh my
father's Egyptian I speak Arabic um and
so does he so
um we quick quickly built a lot of trust
and uh you know I could tell that like
months after month after month
um he was trying to introduce me to more
and more and more of the business and my
dad has no idea what's going on you know
what I mean he just sees the
the
how do I word this the face that they
want to show you know what I mean like
he's spoken to the man before but he has
no idea what the man's doing
um and he thinks he's a great guy
um so uh yeah so my dad's really happy
the owner's calling him every so often
like hey your son's killing it and
meanwhile you know it's killing it in a
different way it's not you know killing
it like being sober
um and then you know it worked out
really well
um I ended up buying a vehicle
um a nice vehicle too a BMW
um and then I bought myself a Lexus uh
kind of like just I had money floating
around that like I really didn't know
what to do with and this was the first
time I've ever had it like that this is
all through the body program right yeah
and um and then I got myself an
apartment uh a condo in uh Santa Monica
right off the Promenade and this lasted
for I'd say about six to eight months
mostly sober
um smoking weed here and there and
um maybe a like coupling or something
like that but in my life what I thought
was so good was that I knew that if I
picked up all that everything that I
built up was gonna be you know thrown in
the garbage
um but uh
anyway moving forward
um
I start hearing rumors about the uh the
owner and the program director that are
there and you know everyone's got
something to say about
um people that you know are in this
industry so I took it with a grain of
salt
um and then I started seeing things
firsthand that um started to prove some
of the facts that you know were being
sold to me and I really didn't want to
believe it but um
it was uh so
an example one that really hurt me a lot
was uh there was a client
that um was 18 years old and she came
from I want to say Washington State
um with uh alcohol and cocaine problems
and
um you know she started getting into the
whole thing
and one day something went wrong with
either the payment or like an argument
and she started screaming in the middle
of the office with like the therapists
who don't know and the clinical
directors and all that they don't know a
thing
um about you know everything that's
going on and um you know he worn their
ones once or twice and then
um two days later I found out that she
was found in her hotel room which is
owned by the same owner of the treatment
center he owns the hotel
um Dead with uh overdose on fentanyl IV
and this is a 18 year old girl that's
never used a syringe never used heroin
never mind fentanyl
um so that kind of like you know that it
seemed really really sketchy like I
don't think she would do something like
that you know what I mean and then um a
couple more instances like that where
like I wasn't very sure but like you
know I got really bad feelings and then
the one that topped it off was um a
client actually got shot in the head
um and it's all because this client was
sharing in groups a lot of uh details
that I guess weren't appropriate in the
uh
owner's eyes and uh
you know I guess that's how he deals
with it he sat him down a couple times
and then you know when I found out that
that happened that was like that
solidified everything like you know it's
right after two days after he like spent
a half hour in group talking about it
and he ends up shot in the head two
blocks away from the IOP
um where's this facility located
um in Hollywood
yeah
yeah it's uh yeah it did it's yeah so um
anyways uh I kind of get myself out of
it
um
just for like my own sanity because I'm
starting to feel really bad that like
you know I'm making the money on top of
like and I'm doing it myself as well
like I'm putting myself into treatment
so that I can be with the people that
I'm putting and like they can trust me
you know there's a whole bunch of [ __ ]
going on and I'm like you know I need to
like take a step back and like get away
from it
um
so I put myself in Orange County instead
of Los Angeles and I was like you know
it's slow pace
um and I look for the first results on
Google so it'll be organic you know like
not a a body brokering facility
[Music]
um
and sure enough two weeks in I meet
somebody from New Jersey which is where
I'm from and I actually knew him in New
Jersey and um he's driving a BMW and I'm
like hey man you know like you've been
here only like three weeks four weeks
like what's going on
and he's like trying to tell me the
whole thing and I'm like dude like I
just finished this like in Los Angeles
and
um so it kind of died off at that point
a week later it got brought up again and
um he said that like he was going
through my Instagram and saw like uh
some of the belongings that I had
acquired through it and was like yo you
must have been doing you know like
really well
um we're opening three spots and we need
help filling the beds because you know
you don't want our treatment center with
zero beds filled you're gonna be losing
an extreme amount of money daily
um he's like I just need help filling
the beds temporarily uh me and my buddy
his partner
um don't have the capacity to fill up
all three
um right off the bat but eventually we
will and like you know you don't have to
get involved and um this went on for
about a year and a half
um everything started going back to the
way it was before
um all the nice things started to come
the girlfriend came
um and uh this individual was kind of
different he
I feel like he lied so well that
he believed it himself you know what I
mean he's constantly talking about how
Jesus is like just blessing him with
everything that he's got
um and how he's like I If you were to
hear just the
when you hear it without knowing the
individual it sounds great and you're
like wow this is a person that's like
recovered and you know he's doing really
well but when you've gone when you've
spent time and hung out with this
individual after he's gotten sober and
he's doing the things that he's doing
um body broker well not only body broker
now we're we're going to another level
so this is um this is after a year and a
half the facility can pretty much run on
its own but like now we're a three-way
partner
um because we opened up a sober living
and um
they started to tell me so like they
don't normally do that they do that they
are in most control of um anaheim's like
um network of drugs
um and their firearm distribution in
Anaheim is like completely controlled by
them because they have a some type of
connect that is superior to others
um
yeah
um so they slowly start to tell me about
these things and I'm like hey man you
know like that's not really me
um I'm like cool with the other one
because like I can kind of convince
myself that like I'm trying to help
somebody out
um get them off the street you know what
I mean and like at the end of the day
there are a lot of people out there that
have ruined every single family tie
every single friend tie that you know
they just they don't have anything and
they wouldn't survive even if they
wanted to be sober without zero dollars
in Orange County or Los Angeles so there
are the few like five percent of people
that like take the money and actually
you know do what they're supposed to but
um yeah those other activities were
completely like out of my um out of like
I never saw myself doing it I didn't
want anything to do with it and um so
yeah we made that clear
um another year goes by I still have the
same girlfriend and um
the girl my girlfriend wants to start
doing this thing and I'm like hey you
know this is a really bad idea
um things go on in these places that
like I really don't want you to be
exposed to like
um
and uh yeah so the buddy of mine the
original partner
um and her started to like kind of get
close
um and he invites her and me to go
hiking in the Mojave
desert
um with his
I want to say fiancee
and two kids
and um so we agree and we're like yeah
you know it sounds like a great idea
like sober fun
um and we're walking we're walking in a
park ranger comes by and um
my buddy's like hey man hold this book
back bro like I'm like why he's like
because uh where you got the two kids
with us and I have a felony I'm and I'm
not supposed to be carrying like any
type of weapon
and I'm like why did you bring like a
weapon to the Mojave Desert like you
know it's not it's a bobcat or you know
I I don't know
um but uh long story short they're
um we're walking and we started to see I
started to see like little blue pills
and red pills and orange strips on the
floor and it was um there were perfect
30s Adderalls and Suboxones and come to
find out that these two the partners and
you know behind my back but using my
money
um in the share of the company
um we're having drop-offs in the desert
from God knows who you know what I mean
of thousands of pills which they would
then push on to whoever they wanted to
mainly the clients
um and they were all fake pills the perk
30s were all fit and all pressed
um the Adderalls were all meth-pressed
and the Suboxone was Suboxone
um and then
um so the package exploded apparently
and we're looking everywhere for it it
takes hours
um
and then we finally find the package and
um he's like hey man we just got one
more thing to take care of and he's like
I'm gonna tell the girls to go take a
walk and um we're gonna walk to this
location and he has a pin set up on his
phone
um
so uh
yeah we send the girls off with the kids
and I'm getting a really really bad
feeling and out of nowhere our third
partner just appears in the desert just
like out of nowhere and he's like hey
what's up guys and I'm like bro like
we've been walking for a while like
hours you know like where did you come
from and he's like oh you know he
invited me and I'm so I'm I'm getting a
really bad like pain in my stomach like
I feel like something's about to go
really wrong
and um so we're sitting down for about
I'd say like five minutes still and I'm
like hey man like what are we doing bro
like what's going on and
um he's uh he's just not saying anything
and so finally he Taps his buddy
um on the shoulder and he's like there
they are and then I'm like bro what's
happening and he's like you see those
two over there and I'm like I'm gonna
look pretty far like and it's a couple
um he's like they gotta go bro he's like
they're extremely detrimental it's a
our safety and our freedom and you know
it's I'm just not willing to you know
risk it like they gotta go
and I'm like bro I'm not no like I'm not
doing this I don't even know them but I
still like I refuse to do this
and you know thinking back on it after
the situation happened this individual
is so determined to
you know do what he does that he's
willing to bring his fiance and
five-year-old and seven-year-old kid
with him to do these types of activities
just for cover and I asked him I'm like
why did you bring them like the you know
why didn't you just bring guys like to
go do this and he was like because if a
park ranger walks by it looks less
suspicious
um and um yeah so sure enough they give
me uh one of the ghost guns that are 3D
printed and I like
I've I don't know what to do at this
point because I feel like if I don't
react in the manner that they want
um
I'm already in the desert you know what
I mean it's not going to be another
thing to you know just leave somebody
there
so um he's like all right on the count
of three bro he's like I'll take the guy
and then he's like you and homeboy uh
the other individual the third party uh
third uh partner I can take the uh the
other one and um
yeah he calls it out first one boom done
falls off the cliff is guaranteed gone
and he's like go for the second and
the third partner waited I want to say
seven seconds before letting off a
single shot I think just to see you know
how like how committed or if I would do
it or not
um and I let off three rounds completely
missing the individual like I would
literally like go like that like towards
the individual and then point away and
fire and like they caught on and um you
know we're walking back and he's like yo
what happened back there bro and I'm
like look man I'm not cut out for this
[ __ ] like I'm not this is not my you
know I wasn't brought up like to do
these things like you know I'm this
isn't what I want in my life and he was
like it's all right man we'll teach you
bro like it was just you know just
little by little and I'm like you know
dog like I don't want to do this at all
he's like yo don't worry bro I'll teach
you uh tactics and different ways that
you can cope with
um this so that uh you know it won't
bother you anymore
and
um I go back to the house my girlfriend
automatically knows something's wrong
um she's like what's going on what's
going on I can't say anything
um and the owner of one of the places
that so we owned uh our own facility but
we would fill those beds up very easily
and then we would work together with
other owners to fill their beds in order
to keep cash flowing
um so one of the owners that we worked
with was a priest
and you know I'm just kind of losing it
like after a week like my brain's like
not working with me you know like the
way I watch the person just lose their
their life and like their body just tip
over the rock like that thing kept
replaying in my head like over and over
and over and over again and I couldn't
get it out
um so I know that if you talk to a
priest
um it's the safest bet a police officer
can interrogate them you know what I
mean and I wouldn't be throwing my
friend under the bus so um I speak to
the owner and I'm like hey man like can
I talk to you about something that like
you know I don't want like and be
insured with anybody else
um and I tell them and he's like nah man
are you sure and you know he's just it
kills me too because I know him and he's
like with the
I guess gang affiliation thing but to a
point you know what I mean because he
still has a congregation that he leads
every Sunday and um so yeah it's he's
like balancing this like tiptoeing this
line
um and I tell him about it he tries to
make an excuse for him I'm sure he knows
that that man is fully capable of you
know doing whatever he does
um but uh so he pretty much tells me you
know like he didn't do anything don't
worry about it
um and two days later I get a phone call
extremely angry phone call
from um my buddy and he's like hey man
like what the [ __ ] bro like why would
you like you know snitch me out to
anybody why would you say that to
anybody like you know this is some
sensitive information and
um long story short uh I end up having
to leave California with like what I
have because
the way he ended the conversation was
extremely threatening
and I felt like if I didn't leave the
area I would not be alive very very soon
so I ended up going to Arizona to who
the girlfriend that I was with when I
first started is now my ex-girlfriend I
drive to Arizona four or five hours away
to go stay at her house and I still
haven't told her what happened and you
know she still knows something wrong
something's wrong
um we ended on good terms luckily though
so she let me stay there and I'm getting
like countless amounts of phone calls
from this individual
um three to four months go by and
um I returned to LA
and I'm not gonna lie not even 36 hours
with him being back in La I'm starting
to see
um
same vehicle starting to lap the block
um same individuals starting to like go
by
um just things that you know were off
and by the way my drug of choice is not
methamphetamine so it wasn't something
that like I was paranoid or anything
um it was just like this repetitive
thing and you know I'm not stupid I can
I'm very knowledgeable on cars I'll read
the license plate if I start getting
sketched to see if it's the same car
that you know lap in the block
um and uh I try to call him and he
doesn't answer the phone and you know I
try to call him again and again and
again and again and so I I leave again
to Arizona
um return after four months again and
same thing happens and this time I'm
like you know I can't like keep running
like I gotta do something so like I
start trying to get involved in a
program and like you know do what I'm
supposed to
and sure enough you know even if the
meetings there's cars that we just park
in the parking lot and not go inside and
just sit there and like the people look
so sketchy and the car would be full
um and so uh I'll end it here
um the way I found out 100 that this was
the individual was that um I was on I
don't know if it's the green line or
which line it is but
um this uh it's a very rural stop it's
like so far away from like Society you
know what I mean where like if anything
were to happen it's not nobody's gonna
know and it was really really late at
night
and um the same people were at the train
station for over two to three hours I
was riding the train back and forth
because I was homeless and you know I
didn't want to sleep in the cold so I
would just hop on the train go one way
and then back and then one way and then
back and um the same people were just
rioting over and over and over again and
like making gestures and laughing
and they are of Spanish descent
and I don't think they realize that I
speak Spanish
um but thank God my mother's Colombian
so I do speak Spanish and I would catch
like inappropriate things that they
would say that they don't think I
understand
um and yeah so after that I couldn't
stay on the train anymore I I felt like
it was like seconds before it was gonna
happen I go down at the main stop the
last stop and I go down the stairs and
in the parking lot
is unmistakable he has an S-Class
Mercedes-Benz that's two-tone like the
the bodies one color and then the top is
another color
um
um and so it's an unmistakable car like
you know it's him automatically you see
that car coming down the road you know
it's him
um and I see it and it drives off right
away like once he sees me and I'm like
oh my God and um
yeah so I haven't been able to really do
anything other than um you know just
keep my head down I tried apologizing
like over the phone just to satisfy his
needs even though I don't feel like I
need to apologize
um I don't think he should have put me
in a position like that without giving
me a heads up first
um but uh yeah you know I guess he's in
a totally different mindset and world of
you know whatever's going on than I am
like yeah I thought this was one thing
and he's totally like somewhere else you
know
so yeah so where do you stay now you're
just you're just running around
um so yeah uh unfortunately uh that was
the last time I went to a treatment
center
um oh my God was this this was I want to
say close to about six months ago so
it's not too far away
um but it's just really unfortunate
because uh
the whole time I was marketing I was
still running my insurance as if I were
you know so it's like I was constantly
in treatment
um and I've completed
countless amounts of treatment I want to
say 50 to 60. and like a lot of them
were like real like you know like I even
though they do the Shady things that
they do they still want you to be sober
in the house they don't go [ __ ] what you
do when you walk out but they don't want
people overdosing ambulance fire
department police showing up you know
what I mean it's just really bad for how
they look
um but uh yeah so you know every time I
get like 30 60 90 days and then
the second I get out or most of the time
it's the day I get out that I relapse
I'd say about 75 to 80 and then the
other 20 is just uh the longest I've
ever had was five months and um that was
just like you know I try to keep myself
as busy as possible go to the gym go to
meetings like you know but eventually I
just get bored like you know and I just
want more like and your drug is fentanyl
um any type of opiate honestly not
fentanyl preferably I'm from New Jersey
so we have uh China White heroin which
is like a small small amount of fentanyl
mixed with Heroin
um but out here I have no choice but
Sentinel you know what I'm saying if I
had the choice I would definitely go
back to doing what I was doing back home
um but tar is not an option for me and
yeah so coming on YouTube and telling
this story yeah that's uh not something
I've ever really done
um and you know I'm definitely gonna
follow up on the video and you know see
what kind of comments come up but um you
know I'm usually very uh
no I don't want to say secretive but
very quiet about the uh circumstances
that surround this just for the fact
that when the way I was raised by my
family since they're both from different
countries and born in those other
countries
um it's very unacceptable to speak about
family things outside of the family you
know what I mean it's kind of like the
mob like what happens in the family
stays in the family like we'll take care
of it like nobody needs to know
um and that prevented me from like you
know really sharing a lot of things and
treatment for the first 10 to 15 times
and then eventually I started to realize
like my dad told me he's like you know
[ __ ] that like say whatever you need to
say to like like just whatever it gets
you to stop just like please and it
kills me because my dad used to hassle
me I so I graduated from NYU with a 3.8
um my dad used to hassle me about like
my efforts on projects
um the amount of time that I would study
you know what I mean like like a proud
father and like you know I'd have I had
a full-time job with ATT as well
um and I'm juggling both of those things
and you know he's still like on my ass
about things like you know your fault
you know you could have did this better
could have did that better
and you know it just kind of kills me to
see that now it's like um
you know just don't just stop using like
you know like if we get school like uh
I'm supposed to go to since I graduated
with my bachelor's I was supposed to go
to law school at NYU and I got accepted
but I had this whole problem so I sent
them a letter saying I had a medical
emergency that I needed to take care of
this was like two years ago and um it's
just been I've never I've never returned
um I thank God that uh why you started
at the end of my senior year because it
got very nasty very quickly and there's
no way that I would have graduated
um had it started any earlier
um but yeah you know it just it kills me
to see the the expectations that my
parents had and you know what they
wanted from me
to where they're still like providing so
much support like you know talking on
the phone like you can do it you can do
this you can do this but like all they
want me to do is like just not use you
know just do whatever like he's like I
don't care what you do like that's even
an option for you
you know I I it is it's easy for me to
get sober like I said I've done it 50 to
60 times to detox I can go through it
like nothing it's the longevity that
like eventually I just
like I don't know I crave the
mixture of Chaos
the feeling the
the no not caring about anything other
than myself you know
which sounds really nasty hearing it
come out of my mouth but
it's it's the truth it's that's it
that's that's what it is it's you know
like
when I'm
doing the other things like being sober
I have to take care of car payments car
insurance I'm sending gifts to my mom
gives to my dad you know all these
things and then when I start using I can
just cut myself off and like you know I
don't have to do anything other than
just focus on getting a stacked for the
day and you know staying well
um which is really sad how old are you
I'm 27. 27.
yeah I mean sharing the story
this is the first time I've ever shared
this story with anybody actually help
protect you rather than make you more
vulnerable right right right I really do
hope so because a couple hundred people
will probably see this video right right
yeah
um
that might actually help you stay safe
yeah I mean it's not not even a matter
of me it's it's it's to the point where
I I refuse to to put anybody in
treatment ever again for you know
payment I won't even put them in
treatment like period also let me just
go to Google because I can't like
but um how many of the treatments are
like this you think
80 percent in California right now 80
but it goes out in other states too yeah
um Florida is the original uh state that
started it
um it just got so out of hand that
um it became way too obvious and they
decided to move all the top people that
had already made their money in Florida
and were able to make it over here came
over here and started just popping them
up left and right and you know
apparently it's not that difficult to
open a treatment center I own the sober
living under my name and I was doing
running uas like charging insurance
companies like like it's nothing and
it's really really simple and
since it's in California California has
a special wall that you can run it out
of a house so we were doing it out of an
Airbnb we didn't even rent the house
lease the house owned the house we were
doing it out of airbnbs and
um yeah just because we didn't have the
uh Capital to you know provide a for the
lease or you know the credibility in the
beginning and you know it's it's it's
it's just crazy how um
how lucrative and how easy it is to
to you know just fall into the the wrong
path you're more than likely to come
across
the wrong path and the right path in
treatment nowadays in California and
it's it's really sad because somebody
out of the group of 30 or 50 or whatever
amount of people knows about it and
they're going to tell you about it and
you're going to be pissed that you're
spending your 30 days and he's getting
five thousand six thousand eight
thousand and you're getting nothing and
yeah
wow
Abraham thank you so much for sharing
the story thank you thank you for having
me stay safe yes sure I wish you the
best of luck I'd love to hear that
you're in law school one day yeah sure I
guess I really want to finish that man I
don't want to serve that bachelor's
degree away it's kind of useless right
now because you know without the law
school it's not it's nice to hear your
parents are still sticking by you too
yeah yeah thank you very much man thank
you God bless